oh damn check that it out what is that  oh I didn't know they made them like  that I don't even understand what I'm  seeing oh I would love to see what's  under there I am really curious about  that I mean I have no idea well you know  we we obviously have some idea you know  I don't well you know it's uh you know  it's a coochie baby yeah or something  nah man is definitely her lady parts oh  maybe it's just more skin no it's a  vagina  yeah or maybe it's a little face under  there no no is it's definitely gonna be  a vagina why but because she's a girl  and girls have vaginas man what is that  what is a vagina it's a woman's  reproductive organ what are you being  serious right now  thank you purchase all I require  does aliens alien down  you